our body is under constant attack by
various foreign substances that are
potentially dangerous it is the body's
immune system that defends and protects
us from the threat of disease on a daily
basis in the bell prize dogs interactive
production immune responses learn how
our immune system works with the help of
vivid animations and find out which
Nobel prizes have been awarded for
discoveries within the field of
immunology through mr. immuno you'll
learn what happens when harmful bacteria
and viruses invade our body how immunity
is gains what antibodies look like and
do in what way the immune system is
involved in blood transfusions
find out more about how the immune
system works in the immune responses
production on the bell prize walk